- Raven Baxter.
And what.
(upbeat music)
My overall favorite
thing about being part of
That's So Raven would
have to be the camaraderie
we had behind the scenes.
We had such a fun time.
I don't know how many cakes
I've had in my face and hair,
all of the costumes we had,
and the fact that we were a family.
And it just goes to show we
were because a lot of the crew,
hair and makeup team,
and everyone came back
for the installment of Raven's Home.
(upbeat music)
The most outrageous outfit that I've worn
on That's So Raven
would have to be the one
where I was about to marry a prince,
and I was in a red and golden frock.
You know, you had to use words like that
when that outfit comes out.
It was a frock, and it
was very interesting.
And then there's also the one,
actually, in Country Cousins,
that was a black and white,
I used to wear a lot of jean suits,
like jeans with the top to match,
and it was this crayons
colored all on top of it.
Those were the days.
(upbeat music)
Well, Raven Baxter has changed.
She has two kids, they're twins.
She has a job.
She's divorced from Devon,
and she's a grown woman.
Raven Symone, I came
out, and I'm an artist,
I'm a painter.
(upbeat music)
My favorite episode in general,
which was actually the hardest to shoot,
would be Country Cousins
because I played a grandmother,
a father, and a baby,
and myself, and that was a lot of work,
but that one turned out awesome.
A cringe show?
Only because I remember
the drama that it took
to actually get through
it, was Cory's Birthday,
which was with the dancing
iguana and the snake.
They didn't tell me I was
gonna be holding a snake.
I was actually scared and
I will forever be scarred.
(upbeat music)
That's hard because she's had
a lot of quotes and lines.
I'm trying to really
dig in there in my mind
and go through the list of things
because I'm not gonna say
what you think I'm gonna say.
Let's see.
I'll just say betrayed by the booty.
That would be a fun one.
I'll say betrayed by the booty
because we have that today
in our real lives as we toured New York.
Some people were betrayed by their booty.
(upbeat music)
Bobb'e J!
It would be fantastic if
he came on Raven's Home.
I miss him.
Oh, I just saw the episode
where he ran behind the pink car
being chased after dogs.
I was doing research for the new show.
I was like, "Oh my goodness,
Bobb'e J was hilarious.
"How's he doin'?"
How you doin'?
How you doin', Bobb'e J?
(upbeat music)
Do I get to sing with Julie Andrews again?
Yeah, I'm going back on Princess Diaries 3
if I get to sing with Julie Andrews again.
That would be awesome.
I mean, I'm a Mary Poppins fan,
so that's just heaven for me.
(upbeat music)
It was spandex from head to
toe and coils in my hair.
My first crush during that film.
We're not gonna talk about it.
Anyway, moving on.
It was great.
I had a wonderful time with Kirsten.
I had a wonderful time
with the people on the set.
It was cool.
I had the best eel sushi bowl
while filming the first one.
Ever.
You're welcome.
(upbeat music)
We can only hope to have as
many nostalgic characters
come back to Raven's Home as possible.
(upbeat music)
The vision face was a work in progress
for a while between me, my
dad, and just a journey.
And then it just became
real easy and simple.
(upbeat music)
Ya nasty.
I'd not say ya nasty
anymore because it's just,
it's like a couture, petite couture word.
Like it really, it has to be worthy.
(upbeat music)
Yes, similar issues will be presented
as the seasons continue.
As for this season, we
touch on some topics,
but not as in depth as one,
as in depth as body shaming.
We touch on your first wearing makeup
when you're not supposed
to and stealing it,
ways of mothering, ways of parenting,
and lots of other topics for the kids,
but we're gonna dive into the real ones
if we get a second season, for sure.
(upbeat guitar music)
Um, let's see, my favorite
on-screen boyfriend
would have to be Devon,
only because he was like my friend, too,
and we were cool, and
we work together now,
and we've always kept in touch.
He's cool peoples and he's not like weird.
It's okay.
I like him.
(upbeat music)
The cast member I was
closest with would be
Anneliese van der Pol.
We are still close today.
We chilled even after the show ended.
It was funny because,
like, I'm this person.
I don't text you every day.
I might not call you every day.
You might hear from me
maybe like once a month.
But that's because I'm working,
that's 'cause I'm talking
to my mama half the time,
and she understood that.
So we always had tabs on each other.
So I moved here and she called me.
She was like, "You're moving to New York?"
I'm like, "Yeah."
She's like, "I'm already here."
So we had our moment there.
We went out a couple times.
But we've always taken care
of each other on our off time.
(upbeat music)
I did not improvise that
much on That's So Raven
in the beginning.
As we all got comfortable
with who Raven Baxter was
and I understood the guidelines
of what I could and
could not say on Disney,
there were ad libs such
as ya nasty and oh snap.
As I go into Raven's Home, it's funny
'cause I have to tell the kids,
"You can't ad lib yet,"
and they're like, "Why?"
I said, "I don't know.
"It just is.
"It works, I promise.
"I hated it too, but do it."
So that's just how it is right now.
It's fun and I'm trying
my best not to ad lib.
They used to call me AW, As Written,
because I just wouldn't do it.
And now my memory is real bad.
Oh, I feel so bad for them.
I love you.
(upbeat music)
In playing a mother there's, you know,
I have responsibilities and jobs to hold.
And especially on Disney Channel
you're not gonna, you know,
there's a big difference obviously
because this is a kids' program for sure.
This is about my twins,
this is about Chelsea's son
and their next door neighbor
and we just happen to be the parents,
but we're still crazy.
Like, we're still teenager-ish,
I guess we have to say,
and Anneliese and I are
always checking each other
saying, "We have to make
sure that we're a parent.
"We have to make sure that
we're acting like parents,"
because it's hard because
Raven and Chelsea, we're crazy.
We have problems, even as adults.
(upbeat music)
How 'bout I do you one better.
I remember the lyrics to my first song
released on MCA records when I was five.
Of course I remember the lyrics to
That's So Raven theme song.
But here's my question to you:
Do you know the lyrics to
the Raven's Home theme song?
(upbeat music)